Japanese Advice 9th Do you think it is difficult for Michimoto
to study another language at the same time as studying Japanese
? It's
more difficult for me than it is now.  My
English proficiency is getting worse and worse
just by studying that Japanese
. Even before this,
I couldn't distinguish between Rent and Taine. Tips for studying technical terms The
most efficient study method
Please tell me how to learn
What should I do if I want to know computer terms
? I think this can be used at any of those branches, but
the animation
is set to indicate the theme of the field.
I
think it's better to find and repeat
it.I don't know how to pronounce this on a computer, so I took a
little note,
but I think the
serial experiment to rain
is good, but if it's this
, don't look too much.  Like
What do you think is the most useful skill in Japan?
Ability to write kanji
Speaking ability
I
think that
speaking ability is the most useful
skill Michimoto-san
Please tell me the recommended YouTuber and content creator.
Yeah,
I especially like history, geography, comedy
and gaming,
so please tell me the people around
you. When you have time to watch youtube
Basically, I'm watching a guy who is studying, isn't
it?
Why
haven't I been watching so often lately?
Atsuhiko Nakata youtube
I'm watching a university t channel.
Well, for
example, I'm explaining an economic book or that book,
right? Well, there is economy, there is history, and there
aren't many causes, but I often
love him a.  There are books, anime, and manga that are said to be masterpieces, and
there are things like commentary and acting in the exchange month. I think there were videos that were insanely
interesting and had English subtitles
.
I don't think
I think it's better to speak, right? I want to talk like a yakuza,
but what should I do?
That's right. I
think it's better to listen to Shiina Ringo's music
. I want to learn Japanese,
but its efficiency.  Please tell me a good learning method. Please tell me the
order. What do you think you should study from the beginning
? A I will answer this a
little seriously
.  There are people who say that, but he
also recommends a study method Immersion
Always listen to Japanese I
think this is the most correct and most efficient.
Unfortunately
, I don't understand it, but if I try to invite it,
I can't do it. Ordinarily
deko I don't understand it, but rather
the Japanese I've heard so far.
If you add all of them, it's a pattern of
20 hours, of course, that person
can't pronounce Japanese,
so for the time being, spend a year
listening to as much Japanese as possible every day and then
talking a little.  By doing so,
if you have a solid input, it will be
overwhelmingly pronounced and pronounced compared to those who do not, and
even if it is grammar, it will be in
that state.
So
it's better to input it for the time being,
Mad says ab 4 d 4
Well,
I'm making a site website app program, so
I might check it.
I'll put a link below.
There are a lot of synonyms in Japanese, right? I have a lot of things like me, right? I
don't know where to use it,
so please move it around for a
while.  Do
n't use synonyms like this. I'm
a pretty social person
. I love talking when I'm away from people, but
I don't want to feel like a foreigner.
What kind of foreigner do you think this is?  Even if you are a quiet and introverted
foreigner, you may be treated like a noisy foreigner
,
so I think you should think that it can't be helped
.  ---
Michimoto-san's recommended
manga or
reading reading Dotoumi to the sea
Manga book or something recommended If it's a
bound, well, my favorite guy
was a manga manga
I don't know for a moment, but maybe  It was
a
manga
, but I'm sorry I haven't read any manga, but I'm sorry, but the 4th
person is really funny.
I think monsters are
good I think it's okay if it's intermediate level
, because the setting of that monster
is relatively realistic, maybe not most of the
anime
But most of the time, the reality setting of the popular manga
isn't realistic, for
example, the
fact that it's a round
, the giant of the advance, etc.
It's not realistic, isn't it? It's
quite a process. The
two word kings that appear there
can't be used in the daily conversation Ichijokai
.  It's a monster, and the animation is
real and the setting is realistic.
Rather than
reading that manga, I wonder if you're a
murderer in-house
.
I don't think it's a life-threatening manga,
but
there are many everyday conversations in that
anime.  If it's a monster, it's
too interesting to match my level, but maybe
I want to come and read it, but
I think I'll definitely want to watch it until the end, so I
recommend it.
What should I do if I don't want to be told that
Japan is long?
If you move to Japan, the
number of times you are good at Japanese will decrease dramatically in that daily conversation, so you
should improve as much as possible before moving to Japan
.